andrew in los angeles california andrew
what's up brother how are we doing
hey how's it going john all right man
hey
it is early out there you sound like
you're a cash brother you doing all
right
yeah no i i haven't slept much so ah man
i hate that for you dude so what's up
how can i help
okay so um a little over two years
i'm 25 and a little over two years ago
uh
exactly three months after i got married
i
was working and i suffered an accident
where someone ran over my feet and
crushed my nerves
and left me disabled for the rest of my
life
i'm constantly in pain and
i guess what i wanted to ask is i've
been i've been diagnosed with like ptsd
and anxiety and i struggle really bad
with it
um constantly have episodes with
triggers
things that like such as
the things that i got ran over with and
um would you get run over with
um someone used an electrical pallet
jack and bulldozed
a bunch of pallets over my feet and
yeah i mean i'm grateful i if i i fell
forward
if i had fallen back i would have fallen
into a
giant garbage compactor and probably
died yes
so are you able to walk now um i use a
wheelchair
and i use crutches okay i'm limited
okay so um yeah it's just it's just been
really hard on me and my wife my wife
has been
great but i constantly deal with like
nightmares night terrors waking up
screaming
waking her up freaking her out having
anxiety attacks i mean i
i was doing pretty good there for a
while but even on sunday like i got
triggered and i just
just can't help it and i don't i don't
know how to work on it
man well i appreciate you i appreciate
your um
vulnerability here and saying this stuff
out loud okay
how have you um how have you tried to
move on what are some things you tried
to do
um well i went through counseling for a
while okay
but i just uh i couldn't keep up with
paying for it so i'm in the middle of
doing social security i want to get back
on
to therapy and stuff like that but i
also i
i come by three times a month
out of my own pocket so i mean
yeah it is what it is you do what three
times a month
uh i have a therapist come to my home i
work with me three times a month
okay so yeah um
so there's there's several things here
but i want to get right to the crux of
it okay so this happened how many years
ago a little over two years a little
over two years
like it's been such a such a
different such a crazy thing that's
happened because it's not like i was
worse from the beginning
i actually got worse with time and i
listened to the doctors and
with practice i got worse
unfortunately like they stuck needles in
my foot and
made me worse and pain got worse and
things like that it just
and even like all the while life was
crazy
my brother died from an overdose and i
had to push through my pain and
made my foot worse through all that
it's just i i'm not
i have a pretty high pain tolerance so
it is what it is but i do the best i can
i don't work anymore but it's just this
this constant fear of like my wife is
going to leave me and
these constant nightmares and and it's
the constant nightmares of the accident
or
even somewhere it's like i want to kill
like my
my dreams like in my dreams i want to
kill myself yeah
and it's just like this this accident
has like
really made things hard yeah
so mentally like i've never experienced
it yeah man
um all right so i'm gonna be pretty
direct with you is that cool
yeah okay um
at some point whether that's today or
whether that's in a year
whether that's in three years or ten
years
at some point you're gonna have to come
to terms with this is
your life and you have not yet
you are continuing to
live in the i can't believe this
happened part of this
and make no mistake this sucks you were
it
i hate that it happened to you you're a
victim of this thing
you were just standing there minding
your business and somebody ran over your
feet it happened
and it's awful and it has altered the
way you will live your life
maybe even forever and then there's a
period at the end of that sentence
and the next sentence to be written is
you're sitting there with a pin in your
hand
and right now the sentence you are
choosing to write is
this sucks this is miserable she's
probably going to leave this sucks i
can't believe my brother died this is
miserable this sucks i hate it i hate it
i hate
it
and all of that is true and
it's not doing one thing to make your
situation better
so when you are ready here's what you're
gonna have to do
you're going to have to fully grieve
what was
you were a 23 year old guy you had just
gotten married it was party time you
were living it up in
southern california it was on it was on
it was on and then suddenly it wasn't
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and you're going to have to be around
people who will grieve that with you
grief has to be seen by others or it
just goes inside
and then you're going to have to decide
who you're going to be on the back end
of this
you cannot at 25 years old cash out from
working
we have too much innate value in
contribution
and if you live a life where you aren't
contributing to
your community to your country to an a
job to your spouse
you will implode from the inside out and
you will drown everyone around you
yourself included
so you've got to be about what a meeting
am i going to make from what happened to
me
am i going to run an e-commerce business
am i going to work from home now that
covets happened anybody can work
anywhere for doing anything right
are you going to learn a whole new set
of skills and
use this time at home and crank it out
and be on disability a short time and
get back in the workforce
because i bet you've got a story to tell
and i bet you've got a bajillion people
to inspire
and i bet you can do just about anything
you want to because you've
you've persevered and you've overcome
this
right but at the end of the day you have
to ask yourself this one question
are you ready to move on and for some
reason you're not
i guess it's just been hard because
people constantly be telling
and and i know they're trying to be
positive but like oh you're gonna walk
you know one day you're not gonna hey
hey listen listen you you went right to
what other people are telling you
and i want to know what andrew's telling
andrew
i don't know i'm afraid i'm gonna be
stuck like this okay
so i was told i was gonna be permanently
handicapped the rest of my life
okay so here's the thing let's say that
you are
let's say you are permanently
handicapped the rest of you are in that
chair for the rest of your life
are you done 25 you're cashed out
no you're just going to give up
that's it no what are you going to do
brother
uh honestly i before this happened i
had dreams of i met my wife in bible
college and i eventually wanted to go on
and
work in a church and work eventually one
day
be a pastor okay all that came to a halt
when we left our church about a year ago
now we're
we're starting oh yeah we just started
going to a new one so kind of starting
over right now
so every single thing you just mentioned
you can do from your home
you can go to seminary from your house
you can
watch a bajillion youtube videos and
learn how to speak
you can create a podcast from your house
you can do home ministry people can come
to you you can go to them
if you're mobile
you can write you can start a blog
called living through paint you can do a
million things andrew but right now
you're blinded by
the voices of other people pumping you
up
you're blinded by the voices of other
people cutting you off at the knees
literally right so you got one group of
people saying oh you're going to be
playing tennis again soon and you've got
other people saying you will never get
out of that chair again
maybe you've got other people saying why
don't you just cut off your legs so
there you go
very right so here's what here's the the
person who's nobody's listening to you
especially andrew and it's andrew
and you have to decide who goes in your
box
who are you going to listen to from this
point forward
nobody else gets a vote and then you
start with that pin in your hand brother
creating what today and tomorrow's going
to look like and it's going to hurt
and it's going to be frustrating and
there's going to be setbacks
and what's going to happen is you are
going to inch down that road
right like the tortoise in the hair
you're going to inch down that road and
everyone's going to be flying by you and
you're going to keep inching and keep
inching
and keep writing and keep taking
seminary course after seminary course
and applying for jobs and not getting
them and keep applying and reaching out
and getting a coaching certificate
and and and and along the way
you're going to talk to your wife and be
vulnerable and say hey today kind of
sucks and then when days don't suck
you're going to say
how can i honor and love you because
you're not going to keep
leaning on these on these emotional
crutches you've got your physical
crutches you're not going to keep
leaning back like
i know honey but two years ago you're
gonna say cool let's figure this out
and when you hurt you're gonna keep
trying
and you're gonna listen to doctors yeah
okay some doctors screwed up
you go to the next one right find online
those um body movement coaches and begin
to get some flexibility back in your
hips and your knees
right whatever it takes because here's
the alternative andrew
just sitting in the chair man
just sitting in the chair
i've i've been working on that been
pushing myself to do
things more physically lately i mean
last year i was like
completely like confined to the chair
now i've been
using my crutches sometimes even going
out dressed with crutches
so you're seeing a little bit of
movement right the tortoise is slowly
starting to okay
there you go brother but hey you're
talking
you're talking about physical stuff tell
me about your soul man
like that's where i'm struggling like i
i can't control like the nightmares that
i have
i can't control i mean like i have
sleeping aids but i don't like to take
them because they make me feel
hungover pretty much okay so here's the
deal man
listen listen ptsd anxiety depression
those are all alarms
that tell you that your body's setting
off
that this thing is still happening that
you aren't safe you don't have a
community around you right
in these nightmares these loops there
are some pretty clear
and relatively simple ways to stop those
nightmares
okay but it caught it means you have to
be highly intentional in the daytime
so when you have this nightmare i want
you to wake up and write it down
it takes the power away from it when you
put it on a piece of paper
during the day i want you to write down
the most recurring nightmare
right the one that you are that that
that forklift is coming right at you
that front end loader is coming right at
you
right and what i want you to do is i
want you to write it down but this time
i want you to change the ending
that it misses right that somebody
blows the whistle and the whole thing
stops and you're safe and you walk away
i want you to write that down on a piece
of paper and then i want you to
to read it a couple of times a day a
couple of times a day
and what's going to happen is your
nightmares are going to be released your
body is going to go
andrew's back in charge because right
now andrew's not in charge man you
cashed out
and that's okay i understand you were
you suffered a bad trauma
and so what your body is trying to do is
take care of andrew because andrew's not
taking care of andrew
and so every scary thing in the world
it's setting off every alarm you got
when you're asleep when you're awake
when you're when you're not paying
attention it sets off your anxiety when
your anxiety is up it
it wants you just to get under the
covers and sleep right with that
depression
it is trying to take care of you because
andrew's not online and you got to bring
andrew back online
and that means you got to grieve what
happened decide there's a period at the
end of that sentence it happened
and now what is andrew going to be about
in the future who is andrew gonna be
and that is an emotional psychological
spiritual exercise where every day
you're writing down a gratitude journal
every day you're writing you're here's
who i'm gonna be today
and then you're gonna be really graceful
with yourself you're gonna have a
community of people with you
who's walking this with you man um
my wife and then i just uh i just had
some
a couple of my friends just come back
from the military
that's awesome and uh they uh they
didn't really know how bad things were
until we sat down and talked and awesome
now they're
they're they're trying to be there for
me and they check up on me now
so once hey once a week once a week
you're going to have a group called
andy's army and y'all going to get
together for
drinks or hanging out or having coffee
or tea whatever it is you'll do you're
gonna do it once a week
and you're not always gonna talk about
the accident you're gonna talk about
what's going on each other's lives and
your marriages and whatever
and listen sitting there every day
wondering if she's gonna leave you if
she's gonna leave you is going to
certify one thing she's probably going
to leave you
instead of it's it's anticipatory
anxiety
right you are projecting a fear into the
future and you are worrying about it now
as though it's happening
i want everything though like every time
that i have
thought about this she reassures me that
that's not gonna happen
okay there's no indication that that
would happen in real life it's just like
a subconscious fear that i've i've had
since
yeah and here's the deal man your your
body has experienced the worst and so it
is
mining any possible future worst in
trying to protect you from it now
and what it's going to do is drown
everybody around you
so instead of worrying about when that
thought pops in your head she's going to
leave you i want you to say out loud
nope she's here for good and
i'm gonna be an incredible partner i'm
gonna be a great husband
and you and her are gonna already have
talked about these things y'all are
gonna do together
right so you're talking about being a
husband talking about possibly being a
dad
talking about getting back into the
workforce being somebody who leads other
people
all of this is beautiful and the ptsd
the anxiety the depression
listen your body is working perfectly it
is trying to take care of you and
protect you
it is trying to care for you because you
got hurt bad
and so what you have to do is let your
body know let your wife know
let your buddies who just got back from
the army who are going to start coming
over your house once a week to hang out
let everybody know andrew's coming back
online
and that starts with picking up that pin
and writing the next chapter of your
story
and it's going to hurt and it's going to
suck and you've got to have people with
you
and you're going to keep writing and
you're going to keep writing and there's
going to be weeks
that you get buried and you write
nothing and then you're going to pick
that pin back up and you're going to
write a gratitude journal again
you're going to write your affirmations
again you're going to keep working on
your physical body you're going to keep
working on your head you're going to
read
books you're going to take online
classes you're going to contribute
to something and you're going to decide
at 25 i'm not cashing out and to you to
those y'all listening to this
at 35 at 55 that's 75 i'm not cashing
out
life is made up of tragedy and trauma
and ugliness and brokenness and
accidents and somebody treating you but
it's that's that's
life and that's why we have other people
in our lives
that's why we try to take care of
ourselves and then we got that pin
that lonely lonely pen to write the next
thing and the next thing and the next
thing
andrew i believe in you and as you walk
through this i want you to keep in touch
with us
as we keep going all right